once we once we recorded let me know
that this will be on the podcast that's
all i want to know
as well okay what i'm about to say we
are recording
so this is going to be in the pocket you
shut up and let me introduce you for one
second
i just want you i want to first off just
thank you guys thank you for wearing
makeup that helps the podcast a lot
thank you so much
i appreciate it i'm happy that you
didn't dye your hair since the gray
hairs are coming
yeah because that's that's all peppers
that's a sexy thing
yeah all right can i just
let's say thanks to sophia for the extra
layer of fake tan that she's pretty yes
thank you so much let's see how talented
sistine is
did an intro can you read let's go i
yeah here we go speak into the mic
you may have seen this tall leprechaun
creeping on sunset boulevard
croupping is [ __ ] up already is it
creeping yeah
oh wow i was like is croupping a word i
don't even know
i didn't even know i was like is that
the new word i've heard no i was like
stop i'm going to people i'm just
nervous i love you
come on group let's go his age still
remains a mystery
and he brags about owning a farm with
cows we have comedian
author podcaster and irish potato mark
hayes
all right and now for the best part here
we go frat boy turns stan
hey guys what do you mean huh oh okay
let me see your drinks turn around
what are we doing frat boy turn stand up
comedian and fellow podcaster
he once tweeted oatmeal is tricky
and might just roast you if you stand
too close
it's michael you're not cheating what
was the last part
no i said if he might just roast you if
you stand too close
yeah or if you look like you guys but
yeah
hey wow we're really
um we're really excited i was excited to
have you guys on
now i don't know i'm happy we assumed a
bit of alcohol i feel like i've
been humbled before this i'm a little
excited yeah i don't know i didn't
realize that this was the beginning of a
relationship between
me and sistine i didn't realize that
that was what was going on we'll get
into that
i feel a
we haven't seen you guys i want to get
into how we met
we'll get into that but i want we
haven't seen you guys all of quarantine
and i want to know
your fault i
i've been [ __ ] lonely as hell and i'm
just like hey would you guys want to
maybe hang out and i'm like well now
it's like i'm chasing yeah
how many times did you get left unseen
yeah so many times
i respond well yeah yeah i actually
think sistine's one of the best
texters thank you cool don't get too
feeling i don't know
i just heard it i'll
[Music]
i have to like give myself five minutes
to think of the funny response because i
feel like if i don't respond funny you
guys are okay so i get that we haven't
been seeing you guys
sorry no no whatever i'm down but we've
seen you on social media
and from what i can gather you seem mark
to be doing pretty okay
like normal you you like yeah how the
hell am i coming off
yeah i feel like you've been
normal you keep you know mocking
tick-tockers it's the usual
we don't know how old you are why do you
have tick-tock we'll get into that later
and i think i've seen way too many gym
selfies on your end oh nice
no i'm not good one i'm just trying to
i'm trying to i'm trying to inspire
people these girls are back and be on my
side
no i want i actually want it you're good
his hair is i've lost a lot of weight
you actually i want to make the note a
little bit like serious
okay here we go i actually just want to
know like are you okay
[Laughter]
no no i'm not even being funny oh yes i
love this
[Laughter]
he's taking a drink of patron right now
you guys are all friends here i want to
have an open a conversation make money i
feel like
well i mean i don't want to go into
specifics but yeah it's been the worst
time of my life
so i was um yeah my dog died is that
what you wanted to talk about
your twitter and i saw a tweet that you
retweeted from your dog
hold on hold on let me just explain it
so
wade at wade the dog on twitter and
you retweeted a tweet that wade wrote
your dog and he said
he said i died and i don't know why but
i was gonna [ __ ] my
i spit out my breakfast and i felt so
bad i did text you when your dog died
i'm pretty sure i did did you laugh
because you weren't
playing i feel like you guys didn't i
remember i didn't wow these
these [ __ ] stallone sisters
how's your dog you think my dog being
dead is a bit
you think that was a bit you think it
was a bit i was running
where is this girl from where is she
from hey he must be doing a comedy bit
his dog died huh
we're not done i'm not done with talking
about how bad you're doing right now
[Laughter]
i'm not done i would also like to know
um
if you're listening to this is episode
two sorry about episode one you're
welcome
honestly i'm kind of sorry too but we'll
go on for that
so so you want to get into how we met
well do you want to say it or should
i well i'll say it i'm very proud of it
flats in here go for it
i slid in your dms that's right
dms not mine wait wait why not mine was
that first look i was into the system
how did you find me well i i mean i
don't know just like the search thing
like this
no i mean he saw you on the explorer
obviously
and then like over time i had seen you
for like a few months and i was like oh
these girls are cute
i remember and then darker
and then i was thinking about it for a
while and then i was with another buddy
i was like yo
i'm gonna uh who cares i mean they're
not even gonna respond because you know
they won't see it because i do this all
the time and
sure enough uh you responded and boy was
i excited
you sent like i sent you a picture and
not a dick pic you little [ __ ] kids
relax
i sent her a picture wait where were you
headed you're on i was i was on a plane
we were traveling i was doing the road
and um i said to selfie with my buddy
and and then you said to selfie with i
don't know who you were with you were
like i was on a bus i'm not kidding you
yeah with like
17 sorority girls yeah no she was with
me
let's not try to include ourselves but
yeah
i wasn't picked so i need to be involved
in some way shape or form what no but
she did let me see
the looks i have a question did you
think she was going to respond
i didn't know but probably not no no so
were you a little bit so what did you do
when i responded
i i i was i was joyful i was joyful
i went really yes this could be the
beginning of something special oh
hey what's going on i thought there was
something special going on oh
there was what there is there is there
is oh yeah that's a good version i have
a soft spot
oh and i have a hard spot
all right so this is the soft spot your
belly
come on that was a good thing we need to
cut yeah
so we got to the comedy store right or
no before
factory and i didn't want to go alone
because i i thought to myself
stranger danger um don't trust anyone
well it could have been a catfish did
you ever need catfish right
so i said sophia i can't go alone
that's weird why don't you come with me
i met her first by the way you did meet
me first oh did you think i was
succeeding at first no i just recognized
you so
i thought you were christine's mom
no but you guys kept saying i'm like
surprised how
funny you guys are like we could banter
back you said that you can't take it
back
and nice i said that that includes me
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're doing a good job
thank you you're actually doing a great
job on the podcast so i have to say i
have you on as a producer
this is my guest appearance actually he
hasn't given me one caller
you've called me a cow before oh wait a
funny way
you don't say that in america like in
l.a we don't like that yeah yeah you
look like a horse
you look like a little barnyard kitty
you look like a little a nice little hen
[Laughter]
but we thought it was uh so unexpected
when you
just casually brought up that you write
sex poems
oh yeah um but you actually make it like
fun but also to pay rent yeah
you want to tell us about that oh yeah
this is good for you yeah
so i write these dom poems i'll i wrote
one for you
well we'll get into that yeah we'll get
into that i basically when malibu was
burning
i saw all these [ __ ] idiots online
posting naked pictures being like i'm so
sad about malibu so i wrote a little sex
point wait what do you mean like
like girls insta models like insta
models like dudes too don't be like
here's my ass this is me and malibu and
they do
so it doesn't really match what they're
posting oh yeah i'm saying something
some people out of touch yeah people
that are like malibu's
so i wrote like oh jesus malibu's
burning i'm on the beach wow he looks so
beautiful oh it's making me hard
[Laughter]
malibu's burning and then i wrote this
whole sex story as a joke
so you made it more like an unsensitive
thing or a sensitive thing make it
sensible just like a joke of it okay but
then women were like oh right more
and i was like no and then they just
started sending me money really
they just started then can we ask how
much you make for one poem
like last one sold for 740 for one poem
no
what shut up i'll fight
was it a personalized one not she just
saw the title and i blurred out the rest
and she was like can you save that for
me
i feel bad because i asked for one for
free yeah i should have paid you
i thought it was for sophia it was for
valentine's day oh one month i made like
four grand shots what do you do you're
just not
stand you have to preface that this is
yeah valentine's day much further in the
future but i asked mark
to i said oh my god sophia and i are
single for valentine's day i think it'd
be so funny
to make our spirits lifted if you wrote
one for sophia because
i think you have like a little crush on
her so i thought it'd be really
funny and cute yes you didn't know i was
doing this
no i didn't i actually had no idea and
then all since the scene sent me the
photos
he was messaging me over and over i kept
reading and did not respond i didn't
even know what to say
oh my god oh my god can we can we act
that one out
sophie what was your reaction would you
say yeah i didn't expect to read what i
read and then also i thought it was
hilarious and i thought no seriously i
actually liked it it ended up being
funny
you brought mabel into it mark kept
asking me he was like did she like it
did she read it yeah
because that's vulnerable it's his
writing
it really made him feel like you didn't
like his stuff so and then he wanted and
he wonder why he didn't compliment you
enough i think we should talk about
how oh we were tricked tricked
you tricked me first hold on i
get a text from you yeah and you say oh
we should like all get dinner you made
it very casual and i was down
i was down with casual 100 let me
preface this with i wouldn't
it's never a date unless it's one-on-one
yeah forever yes nobody goes on group
dates i've never heard of that in my
life
that's so weird that's weird as [ __ ] so
you asked to get dinner
casual friends and i said yeah okay i'll
bring sophia let everyone know that i
did ask you for a one-on-one thing after
the laughing i don't know how it went
specifically but it didn't go well
would you guys like to know what the
great michael leonochie thought it would
be
but yeah ready yeah should we walk my
crippled dog to the dog
i did i definitely didn't say that i
definitely didn't say that
you wanted to do it let's see i'll pull
it up
a dog park because a dog stuff up
three four he had first of all three
fees i asked you on a normal date i did
not say let's go on a crippling dog walk
date
no those words all right we are going
way off the boat i want to talk about
this double date
i'm gonna take over because i feel like
we're going way off tour wow if she has
to take it over that's how bad
it is so she tells me yeah she says to
me
he wants to take me to dinner with like
friends can you be the friend that comes
with me and i go
all right sure why not so we pull up and
i was like who's the friend that's going
to show up
we're driving we're driving like wait so
who's he
bringing with you guys i don't know we
drive past the restaurant we see
this is how rude she is mike and mark
standing out front and sofia starts
screaming she's like one double date i
really thought this was a double date i
was like
oh oh so it was you you put that in that
[ __ ]
i was just like mark come with me
because he's he's a fun time he's good
with banter and stuff like that
but but also i was like i was like it
wasn't like in my mind i was like we're
going to go out and have drinks dinner
fun and we're going to continue the
night and it was going to have a fun
time
then they walk up they go so you chose
mark and i was like
it was awesome you were going into it
thinking it's going to be a date
no but then the second we saw
him there we were like oh my god because
he asked me out and i was surprised
why didn't you tell me you asked her out
oh [ __ ] it no i said to him
tell them i'm coming or she's gonna get
weird
i didn't [ __ ] think i didn't i didn't
know what they were doing i got
weird all these months i'm thinking this
is all my fault it's all because of what
you guys had going in your hands
hey steve we've always been guys
say again how many times you rejected me
go on
after writing his heart out in a poem to
her so you i didn't know you were mad
no by the way she came home from the
date saying because we were talking
you guys were talking from the date
whatever that you were talking about
your
ex the whole time was that what it was
yeah oh my god you're [ __ ] on your
ass
and he's telling me i look like a sports
illustrated model
like you're smart you're beautiful be on
the cover be on forbes i was like
and he kept by the way he continued it
after so it was great
you on the other hand then she stopped
texting me yeah bye roast
yeah i feel like there wasn't even any
group conversation
it might have as well just been you two
and us too yeah so we're sitting across
from each other
wow how do we save this i listen in
and you are being so lovely you were
like so kind of
you're actually treating it like a
gentleman you're asking her questions
about
work and job and future and and life and
you're you're saying she looks so
beautiful
meanwhile on our side of the
horrible now he's literally pulling
because yeah look at my ex she's so hot
i remember we were both doing that yeah
yeah because we were talking about x's
like casually like oh yeah
and then the whole time was just like a
roast on road by the way
and then i was like i just want to be
part of this side yeah yeah that's
awesome
that's honestly i feel so bad that's so
sweet i didn't know you were that kind
but also they started the date
they started the date that they we sit
down her every time i see her she goes
so who are you dating she does this even
when i got to the podcast studio today
she goes like this and she does this
little
so who are you next time next time i'm
not going to ask
anything at all and you're just saying
totally a [ __ ]
mike she said the same to me she goes
who you did and i said you and she went
[Laughter]
wait she's short-circuited so that
interaction
was so bad it was so bad though
it was so bad that even when we left we
go me and him both go what the
this is how you ended the night you
talked about how you were in college at
a frat party fighting someone and you're
like good night
yeah yeah and i have to say so we gotta
sit in the car we finally wait so we can
be ourselves really
yeah our true followers are simple so
you you guys are so lovely you walk us
through our car
they're mocking us more right and we sit
in our cars and they leave like god this
was traumatized
and sofia i need a drink hold on god
thank god we somehow saved it the funny
thing is mike said to me
don't get drunk and be a [ __ ] idiot
um
to you i will say one thing i have to
say one thing
we sit in the car we sit in the car and
sophia looks to me and she goes
never again no we
love these two there's absolutely no
hate anything that they say to us it's
all
i used to like until you're like i
rejected you for
him sat in
[Laughter]
wait i have a question would you
actually hit on us in
no if you didn't know who we were or
anything are we your type of girl if you
didn't see people on instagram
like what's your type of girl yeah
that's a question i i think she yeah
i've dated blondes brunettes like wait
wait is that yours
she's like she's like why is your type
yeah but i have a personality wise like
oh
for you personality wise yes looks wise
i can get over it first person
i think you both are solid sevens yeah
yeah yeah i'll take yeah
at nighttime
[Music]
watch me compliment sophia and she's
good she's gonna go
come on do it do it all right
don't do it i will do it don't she's
[ __ ] beautiful
oh see
what is wrong what happened yeah did you
stand
yeah she's like she's a dream woman all
right you're
cool wait i feel like i need it don't
[ __ ] compliment me
i feel like i need to compliment this
stupid irishman oh my mark's getting
drunk it's funny
i was doing her accent
do you think is funnier me or sophia
you're going to say sistine
okay because she because it's real
because that's the real answer
[Laughter]
i have to say this has been actually
really [ __ ] funny
oh thank you guys we're having you again
soon
all right let's leave flames get out of
here we're good bye
jesus i'm sweating